the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay folks welcome back hope you had a
nice long weekend with no classes you
got caught up on all those problem sets
that have been sneaking up on you
you enjoyed watching the Patriots and
Tom Brady come back up sorry I'm showing
my local bias before we talk about
today's topic I want to take a second to
set the stage and I want you to stop and
think about what you've seen so far in
this course we're coming up on the end
of the first section of the course and
you've already seen a lot starting to
learn about fundamentals of computation
you've seen different kinds of data
structures both mutable and immutable so
tuples and lists dictionaries different
ways of pulling things together seen a
range of algorithms from simple linear
code to loops fours and Wiles you've
seen iterative algorithms you've seen
recursive algorithms you've seen classes
of algorithms divide and conquer greedy
algorithms bisection search a range of
things and then most recently you saw
pulling things together with classes a
way to group together data that belongs
together along with methods or
procedures that are signed to manipulate
that data so you've had actually a
fairly good coverage already of a lot of
the fundamentals of computation and
you're starting to get geared up to be
able to tackle a pretty interesting
range of problems today and Monday we're
going to take a little bit of a
different look at computation because
now that you've got the tools to start
building up your own personal
armamentarium of tools we'd like to ask
a couple of important questions the
primary one of which is how efficient
are my algorithms and by efficiency
we'll see it refers both to space and
time but primarily to time and we like
to know both how faster my algorithm is
going to run and how could I reason
about that's performance and that's what
we're going to do with today's topics
we're going to talk about orders of
growth we'll define what that means in a
few minutes we're going to talk about
what's called the Big O notation and
we're going to begin to explore
different classes of algorithms
before we do that though let's talk
about why and I want to suggest to you
there are two reasons this is important
to be considering first question is how
could we reason about an algorithm
something you write in order to predict
how much time is it going to need to
solve a problem of a particular size I
might be testing my code on small scale
examples and I want to know if I run it
on a really big one how long is it going
to take can I predict that can I make
guests about how much time I'm going to
need to solve this problem especially if
it's in a real-world circumstance where
time is going to be crucial equally
important is going the other direction
we want you to begin to reason about the
algorithms you write to be able to say
how does certain choices in a design of
an algorithm influence how much time
it's going to take if I choose to do
this recursively is that going to be
different than iteratively if I choose
to do this with a particular kind of
structure in my algorithm what does that
say about the amount of time I'm going
to need and you're going to see there's
a nice association between classes of
algorithms and the interior structure of
them and in particular we want to ask
some fundamental questions are there
fundamental limits to how much time it's
going to take to solve a particular
problem no matter what kind of algorithm
I design around this and we'll see that
there's some nice challenges about that
so that's what we're going to do over
the next two days before we do though
let's maybe ask the obvious question why
should we care could be on a quiz might
matter to you better choice is because
it actually makes a difference and I say
that because it may not be as obvious to
you as it was in an earlier generation
so people with my gray hair or what's
left of my gray hair like to tell
stories I'll make it short but I started
programming 41 years ago
no sorry 45 years ago on punch cards you
don't know what those are unless you've
been to a museum on a machine that
filled a half a room and that took about
five minutes to execute what you can do
in a frack
of a second on your phone right this is
to tell you're living in a great time
not independent of what's going to
happen on November 8th all right we'll
stay away from those topics as well
won't we my point is yeah I tell old
stories I'm an old guy but you might
argue look computers are getting so much
faster does it really matter and I want
to say to you maybe it's obvious to you
yes absolutely it does because in
conjunction with us getting faster
computers we're increasing the sizes of
the problems the data sets we want to
analyze are getting massive and I'll
give you an example I just pull this off
of Google of course in 2014 I don't have
more recent numbers Google's served I
think I have that number right 30
trillion pages on the web see the 30
trillion or 30 quadrillion of you I
can't count that many zeros there it
covered a hundred million gigabytes of
data and I suggest to you if you want to
find a piece of information on the web
can you write a simple little search
algorithm that's going to sequentially
go through all the pages and find
anything in any reasonable amount of
time probably not right it's just
growing away too fast this by the way is
of course why Google makes a lot of
money off of their their MapReduce
algorithm for searching the web written
by the way or co-written by an MIT grad
and the parent of a current MIT student
so there's a nice hook in there not that
Google pays MIT royalties for that
wonderful thing by the way all right bad
jokes aside searching Google ton of time
searching a genomics data set ton of
time the data sets are growing so fast
you're working for the US government you
want to track terrorists using image
surveillance from around the world
growing incredibly rapidly pick a
problem the datasets grow so quickly
that even if the computer speed up you
still need to think about how do I come
up with efficient ways to solve those
problems so I want to suggest you while
sometimes simple solutions are great
they're the easy ones to rate to right
sorry at times you need to be more
sophisticated therefore we want to
reason about how do we measure
efficiency and how do we relate al
design choices to the cost that's going
to be associated with it
okay even when we do that we've got a
choice to make because we could talk
about both efficiency in terms of time
or in terms of space meaning how much
storage do I have inside the computer
and the reason that's relevant is
there's actually in many cases a
trade-off between those two and you've
actually seen an example which you may
or may not remember you may recall when
we introduced dictionaries I showed you
a variation where you could compute
Fibonacci using the dictionary to keep
track of intermediate values and we'll
see you next week that it actually
tremendously reduces the time complexity
that's called a trade-off in the sense
that sometimes I can pre-compute
portions of the answer store them away
so that when I'm trying to a bigger
version of the answer I can just look up
those portions so there's going to be a
trade-off here we're going to focus for
purposes of this lecture in the next one
on time efficiency how much time is it
going to take our algorithms to solve a
problem okay what are the challenges in
doing that before we look at the actual
tools and in fact this is going to lead
into the tools the first one is even if
I've decided on an algorithm there are
lots of ways to implement that a while
loop and a for loop might have slightly
different behavior I could choose to do
it with temporary variables or using
direct substitution lots of little
choices so an algorithm could be
implemented many different ways how do I
measure the actual efficiency of the
algorithm second one is I might forgive
them problem have different choices of
algorithm a recursive solution versus an
iterative one using a dividing conquer'd
versus straightforward search we're
going to see some examples of that so
I've got to somehow separate those
pieces out and in particular I'd like to
separate out the choice of
implementation from the choice of
algorithm I want to measure how hard is
the algorithm not can I come up with a
slightly more efficient way of coming up
with an implementation so here are three
ways I might do it I'm going to look at
each one of them very briefly the
obvious one is we could be scientists
time it write the code run a bunch of
test case run a timer use that to try
and come up with a way of estimating
efficiency we'll see some challenges at
that slightly more abstractly we could
count operations we could say here are
the set of fundamental operations
mathematical operations comparisons
setting values retrieving values and
simply say how many of those operations
do I use in my algorithm as a function
of the size of the input and that could
be used to give us a sense of efficiency
we're going to see both of those are
flawed somewhat more in the first case
than the second one and so we're going
to abstract that second one to a more
abstract notion of something we call an
order of growth and we'll come back to
that in a couple of minutes this is the
one we're going to focus on so one the
computer scientists use it leads to what
we call complexity classes so order
growth or Big O notation is a way of
abstractly describing the behavior of an
algorithm and especially the
equivalences of different algorithms but
let's look at those timing Python
provides a time before you could import
the time module and then you can call as
you can see right down here I might have
defined a really simple little function
converts Celsius to Fahrenheit and in
particular I could invoke the clock
method from the time module and what
that does is it gives me a number as the
the number of some fractions of a second
currently there
having done that I could call the
function and then I could call the clock
again and take the difference to tell me
how much time it took to execute this
it's going to be a tiny amount of time
and then I could certainly print out
some statistics I could do that over a
large number of runs different sizes of
the input and come up with a sense of
how much time does it take here's the
problem with that not a bad idea
again my goal is to evaluate algorithms
do different algorithms have different
amounts of time associated with them the
good news is that if I measure running
time it will certainly vary as the
algorithm changes just what I want to
measure measure sorry
but one of the
is that it will also vary as a function
of the implementation right if I use a
loop that's got a couple of more steps
inside of it in one algorithm than
another it's going to change the time
and I don't really care about that
difference so I'm confounding or
conflating implementation influence on
time with algorithm influence on time
not so good
worse timing will depend on the computer
my Mac here is pretty old while these
four computer versions is about five
years old I'm sure some of you have much
more reason Mac's or other kinds of
machines your speeds may different from
mine that's not going to help me in
trying to measure this and even if I
could measure it on small size problems
that doesn't necessarily predict what
happens when I go to really large size
problems because of issues like the time
it takes to get things out of memory and
bring them back into the computer so
what it says is that timing does vary
based on what I'd like to measure but it
varies on a lot of other factors and
it's really not all that valuable
okay got rid of the first one let's
abstract that abstract I'm going to make
the following assumption I'm going to
identify a set of primitive operations I
kind of get to say what they are but the
obvious one is I say what does the
machine do for me automatically that
would be things like arithmetic or
mathematical operations multiplication
division subtraction comparisons
something equal to another thing
something greater than something less
than assignments set a name to a value
and retrieval from memory I'm going to
assume that all of these operations take
about the same amount of time inside my
machine nice thing here is then it
doesn't matter which machine I'm using
I'm measuring how long does the
algorithm take by counting how many
operations of this type are done inside
of the algorithm and I'm going to use
that count to come up with a number of
operations execute it as a function of
the size of the input and if I'm lucky
that'll give me a sense of what's the
efficiency of the algorithm so this
one's pretty boring it's got three steps
write a multiplication
a division and in addition for if you
count the return but if I had a little
thing here that added up the integers
from 0 up to X I've got a little loop
inside here and I could count operations
so in this case it's just as I said
three operations here I've got one
operation I'm going to doing an
assignment and then inside here in
essence there's one operation to set I
to a value from that iterator initially
it's going to be 0 and then it's going
to be 1 and you get the idea and here
that's actually two operations
it's nice Python shorthand but what is
that operation it says take the value of
total and the value of I add them
together it's one operation and then set
that value or rather set the name total
to that new value so second operation so
you can see in here I've got three
operations and what else do I have well
I'm going to go through this loop x
times all right I do it for I equals 0
then for I equal 1 and so on so I'm
going to run through that loop x times
and if I put that together I get a nice
little expression 1 plus 3 X
actually I've probably cheated Eurasians
they cheated I probably should have
counted the return as one more operation
so that would be 1 plus 3 X plus 1 or 3
X plus 2 operations why should you care
it's a little closer to what I'd like
because now I've got an expression that
tells me something about how much time
is this going to take as I change the
size of the problem
if X is equal to 10 it's going to take
me 32 operations if X is equal to 100
302 operations if X is equal to a
thousand three thousand and two
operations and if I wanted the actual
time I just multiplied that by whatever
that a constant amount of time is for
each operation I've got a good estimate
of that sounds pretty good not quite
what we want but it's close so if I was
counting operations what can I say about
it first of all it certainly depends on
the algorithm that's great number of
operations is going to directly relate
to the algorithm I'm trying to measure
which is what I'm after
unfortunately it still depends a little
bit on the implementation let me show
you what I mean by that by backing up
for a second
suppose I were to change this for loop
to a while loop
I'll set I equal to zero outside of the
loop and then while I is less than X
plus one I'll do the things inside of
that that would actually add one more
operation inside the loop because I both
have to set the value of I and I have to
test the value of I as well as doing the
other operations down here and so rather
than getting three X plus one I would
get four X plus one yeah as the
government says what's the difference
between three and four you know when
you're talking about really big numbers
problem is in terms of counting it does
depend and I want to get rid of that in
a second so it still depends a little
bit on the implementation I remind you I
wanted to measure impact of the
algorithm the other good news is the
count is independent of which computer I
run on as long as all my computers come
with the same set of basic operations I
don't care what the time of my computer
is versus yours to do those operations
I'm measuring how much time it would
take and I should say by the way one of
the reasons I want to do it is less to
know is there going to take 37.4 to
femtoseconds or not but rather to say if
this algorithm has a particular behavior
if I double the size of the input does
that double the amount of time I need
does that quadruple the amount of time I
need does it increase it by a factor of
ten and here what matters isn't the
speed of the computer it's the number of
operations the last one I'm not going to
really worry about but we'd have to
really think about what are the
operations we want to count I made an
assumption that the amount of time it
takes to retrieve something from memory
is the same as the amount of time it
takes to do a numerical computation that
may not be accurate but this one could
probably be dealt with by just agreeing
on what are the common operations and
then doing the measurement so this is
closer excuse me it's certainly not
count varies for different inputs and we
can use it to come up with
a relationship between the inputs and
the count and for the most part it
reflects the algorithm not the
implementation but it still got that
last piece left there so I need to get
rid of the last piece so what can we say
here timing and counting do evaluate or
reflect implementations I don't want
that timing also evaluates the machines
what I want to do is just evaluate the
algorithm and especially I want to
understand how does it scale I'm going
to say what I said a few minutes ago
game if I were to take an algorithm and
I say I know what its complexity is my
question is if I double the size of the
input what does that say to the speed
because that's going to tell me
something about the algorithm I want to
say what happens when I scale it and in
particular I want to relate that to the
size of the input so here's what we're
going to do we're going to introduce
orders of growth some wonderful tool in
computer science and what we're going to
focus on is that idea of counting
operations but we're not going to worry
about small variations whether it's
three or four steps inside of the loop
I'm going to show that that doesn't
matter and if you think about my
statement of does it double in terms of
size or speed or not sorry time or not
whether it goes from 3 to 6 or 4 to 8
it's still a doubling so I don't care
about those pieces inside I'm going to
focus on what happens when the size of
the problem gets arbitrarily large I
don't care about counting things from 0
up to X when X is 10 or 20 what happens
when it's a million a hundred million
what's the asymptotic behavior of this
and I want to relate that time needed
against the size of the input so I can
make that comparison I suggested ok so
to do that we got to do a couple of
things we have to decide what are we
going to measure and then we have to
think about how do we count without
worrying about implementation details so
we're going to express efficiency in
terms of size of input and usually this
is going to be obvious if I've got a
procedure it takes one argument that's
an integer the size of the integer is
the thing I'm going to measure things in
if I double the size of that integer
what happens to the computation if I'm
computing something over a list
typically the length of the list
is going to be the thing I'm going to
use to characterize the size of the
problem if I've got and we'll see this
in a second a function that takes more
than one argument I get to decide what's
the parameter I want to use if I'm
searching to see is this element in that
list typically I want to worry about
what's the size of the list not what's
the size of the element but we have to
specify what is it we're measuring and
we're going to see examples of that in
just a second okay so now we start
thinking about that sounds great
certainly find computing something
numeric sum of integers from 0 up to ax
it's kind of obvious X is the size of my
problem how many steps does it take I
can count that but in some cases the
amount of time the code takes is going
to depend on the input so let's take
this little piece of code here and I do
hope by now even though we flash up code
you're already beginning to recognize
what does it do not the least of which
by the clever name that we chose but
this is obviously just a little function
it runs through a loop running like I
sorry let a for loop that takes I for
each element in the list l and it's
checking to see is i equal to the
element I've provided and what it is I'm
going to return true if I get all the
way through the loop and I didn't find
it I'm going to return false it's just
saying is e in my input list L how many
steps is this going to take
well we can certainly count the number
steps in the loop right we've got a set
I we got to compare I and potentially we
got to return so there's at most three
steps inside the loop but depends on how
lucky I'm feeling right if he happens to
be the first element in the list it goes
through the loop once I'm done great I'm
not always that lucky if E is not in the
list then it will go through this entire
loop until it gets all the way through
the elements of L before saying false so
this sort of a best-case scenario this
is the worst case scenario gain if I'm
assigned and say well let's run some
trials let's do a bunch of examples and
see how many steps does it go through
and that would be the average case on
average I'm
likely to look at half the elements in
the list before I find it right I'm
lucky it's early on if I'm not so lucky
it's later on which one do I use well
we're going to focus on this one because
that gives you an upper bound on the
amount of time it's going to take what
happens in the worst case scenario we
will find at times that's valuable to
look at the average case to give us a
rough sense of what's going to happen on
average but usually when we talk about
complexity we're going to focus on the
worst case behavior so to say it a
little bit different way let's go back
to my example suppose you gave it a list
L of some length length of L would call
that and if you like then my best case
would be the minimum running time and in
this case it would be for the first
element in the list and notice in that
case the number of steps I take would be
independent of the length of L that's
great doesn't matter how long the list
is if I'm always going to find that the
first element I'm done the average case
would be the average over the number of
steps I take depending on the length of
the list is going to grow linearly with
the length of the list it's a good
practical measure but the one I want to
focus on will be the worst case and here
the amount of time as we're going to see
in a couple of slides is linear in the
size of the problem meaning if I double
the length of the list in the worst case
it's going to take me twice as much time
to find that it's not there if I
increase the length of list by factor of
ten in the worst case is going to take
me ten times as much time as it did in
the earlier case to find out that the
problems not there and that linear
relationship is what I want to capture
so we're going to focus on that what's
the worst case behavior and we're about
ready to start talking about orders or
growth but here then it's what orders or
growth are going to provide for me I
want to evaluate efficiency particularly
when the input is very large what
happens when I really scale this up I
want to express the growth of the
programs run time as that input grows
not the exact run time but that notion
of if I double it how much longer does
it take
what's the relationship between
increasing the size of the input and the
increase in the amount of time it takes
to solve it we're going to put an upper
bound on that growth and if you haven't
seen this a math that basically says I
want to come up with a description that
is at least as big as sorry as big as or
bigger than the actual amount of time it
goes it's going to take and I'm going to
not worry about being precise talk about
being order of rather than excite
exactly I don't need to know to the
femtosecond how long this is going to
take or to exactly one operation how
long it's going to take but I want to
say things like this is going to grow
linearly I double the size of the input
it doubles the amount of time or this is
going to grow quadratically I double the
size of the input it's going to take
four times as much time to solve it or
if I'm really lucky this is going to
have constant growth no matter how I
change the input it's not going to take
any more time to do that we're going to
look at the largest factors in the run
time which piece of the program takes
the most time and so in orders of growth
we are going to look for a as tight as
possible an upper bound on the growth as
a function of the size of the input in
the worst case nice long definition
almost ready to look at some examples so
here's the notation we're going to use
it's called Big O notation I have to
admit and John's not here today to
remind me the history I think it comes
because we used Omicron god knows why
sounds like something from Futurama but
we used Omicron as our symbol to define
this I'm having such good luck with bad
jokes today you're not even wincing when
I throw those things out but that's okay
it's called Big O notation we'll you're
going to use it we're going to describe
the rules of it is this the tradition of
it
it describes the worst case because it's
often the bottleneck we're after and as
we've said it's going to express the
growth of the program relative to the
input size okay let's see how we go from
counting operations to getting to orders
the growth then we're going to define
some examples of order growth and we're
gonna start looking at algorithms here's
a piece of code you've seen before again
hopefully you recognize or can see
fairly quickly what it's doing computing
factorial the iterative way basically
remember in fact
oil is n times n minus 1 times n minus 2
all the way down to 1
hopefully assuming in is a non-negative
integer here we're going to set up an
internal variable called answer and then
we're just going to run over a loop as
long as n is bigger than 1 we're going
to multiply answer by n store it back in
to answer decrease them by 1 we'll keep
doing that until we get out of the loop
and we're going to return answer I'm
going to start by counting steps that's
why the way just to remind you that in
fact there are two steps here so what do
I have I've got one step up there to set
answer to one I'm setting up n sorry I'm
not setting up in I'm going to test N
and then I'm going to do two steps here
because I got to multiply answer by N
and then set it to answer and I
similarly got two steps there because
I'm subtracting one from N and then
setting it to n so I've got two plus
four plus the test which is 5 I've got
one outside here I got one outside there
and I'm going to go through this loop n
times so I would suggest it if I count
number of steps it's 1 plus 5n plus 1
okay sort of what we did before 5n plus
2 is the total number of steps that I
use here but now I'm interested in
what's the worst-case behavior well in
this case it is the worst case behavior
because it doesn't have decisions
anywhere in here but I just want to know
what's the asymptotic complexity you
know I'm going to say oh sorry that is
to say I could do this different ways I
could have done this with two steps like
that that would have made it not just
one plus five n plus one would have made
it one plus six n plus one because I've
got an extra step I put that up because
I want to remind you I don't care about
implementation differences and so I want
to know what captures both of those
behaviors and in Big O notation I say
that's order M grows linearly I'm going
to keep doing this to you until you
really do wince at me if I were to
double the size of M whether I use this
version or that version the amount of
time the number of steps is basically
going to double
now you say wait a minute you know five
n plus two you know if I n is is ten
that's fifty two is if n is 20 that's
102 that's not quite doubling and you're
right but remember we really care about
this in the asymptotic case when n gets
really big those extra little pieces
don't matter and so what we're going to
do is we're going to ignore the additive
constants and we're going to ignore the
multiplicative constants when we talk
about orders of growth so what does Oh
Levin measure now I'm just summarizing
here we want to describe how much time
is needed to compute or how does the
amount of time rather needed to compute
a problem grow as the size of the
problem itself grows so we want an
expression that counts that asymptotic
behavior and we're going to focus as a
consequence on the term that grows most
rapidly so here are some examples and I
know if you're following along you can
already see the answers here but we're
going to do this to simply give you a
sense of that if I'm counting operations
and I come up with an expression that
has N squared plus two n plus two
operations that expression I say is
order N squared the two and the two n
don't matter and think about what
happens if you make end really big right
N squared is much more dominant than the
other terms we see that's order N
squared
even this expression we say is order N
squared now in this case for lower
values of n this term is going to be the
big one in terms of number of steps I
have no idea how I wrote such an
inefficient inefficient algorithm that
it took a hundred thousand steps to do
something but if I had that expression
for smaller values of n this matters a
lot this is a really big number but when
I'm interested in the growth and that's
the term that dominates and you see the
idea or begin to see the idea here when
I have sorry before I go back there when
I have expressions if it's a polynomial
expression it's the highest order term
that's the term that captures the
complexity both of these are quadratic
this term is order n because n grows
faster than log of N
this funky-looking term even though that
looks like the big number there and it
is a big number that expression we say
is order n log in because again if I
plot out as how this changes as I make n
really large this term eventually takes
over as the dominant term what about
that one what's the big term there how
many people think it's n to the
thirtieth show of hands how many people
think it's 3 to the N
show of hands thank you you're following
along you're also paying attention how
many people think I should stop asking
questions no show of hands alright but
you're right Exponential's are much
worse than powers even something like
this again it's going to take a big
value of n before Gesser but it does get
there and that by the way is important
because we're going to see later on in
the term that there are some problems
where it's believed that all of the
solutions are exponential and that's a
pain because it says it's always going
to be expensive to compute so that's how
we're going to reason about these things
and to see it visually here are the
difference between difference is between
those different classes something that's
constant the amount of time doesn't
change as I change the size of the input
something that linear grows as a
straight line as you would expect nice
behavior quadratic starts to grow more
quickly log is always better than linear
because it slows down as we increase the
size n log n log in our log linear is a
funky term but we're going to see it's a
very common complexity for really
valuable algorithms and computer science
and it has a nice behavior sort of
between the linear and the quadratic an
exponential blows up just to remind you
of that all right let me show you how
we're going to do the reasoning about
this so here's how we're going to reason
about it we've already seen some code
where I started working through this
process of counting operations here are
the tools I want you to use given a
piece of code you're going to reason
about each chunk of code separately if
you've got sequential pieces of code
then the rules are called the law of
addition for for order of growth is
that the order of growth of the
combination is the combination of the
order of the growth say that quickly ten
times but let's look at an example of
that here are two loops you've already
seen examples of how to reason about
those loops for this one it's linear in
the size of M I'm going to go through
the loop end times doing a constant
amount of things each time around by
what I just showed that's order n this
one again I'm doing a just a constant
number of things inside the loop but
notice that it's N squared so that's
order N squared n times n the
combination is I have to do this work
and then that works so I write that as
saying that is order of n plus order of
N squared but by this up here that is
the same as saying what's the order of
growth of n plus n squared oh yeah we
just saw that says it's n squared so
audition or the law of addition lets me
reason about the fact that this will be
an order N squared algorithm
second we're going to use it's called
the law of multiplication and this says
when I have nested statements or nested
loops I need to reason about those and
in that case what I'm going to argue or
not argue state is that the order of
growth here is a multiplication ideas
when I have nested things I figure out
what's the order of growth of the inner
part what's the order of growth of the
outer part and I'm going to multiply
that try game I'm going to multiply
together those orders of growth to get
the overall order of growth if you think
about it it makes sense look at my
little example here it's a trivial
little example but I'm looping for I
from 0 up to n for every value of I I'm
looping for J from 0 up to n and I'm
printing out a on the phones I'm saying
a along oh come on at least throw
something at me when it's that bad right
want to make sure you're still awake ok
you get the idea but what I want to show
you here is notice the order of growth
that's order in right I'm doing that n
times but I'm doing that for each value
by the outer piece here loops also end
times for each value of I I'm doing
order and things so I'm doing order of n
times order of n steps and by that law
that is the same order of n times N or N
squared so this is a quadratic
expression you're going to see that a
lot nested loops typically typically
have that kind of behavior not always we
typically have that kind of behavior so
what you're going to see is there's a
set of complexity classes and we're
about to start filling these in order
one is constant says amount of time it
takes doesn't depend on the size of the
problem these are really rare that you
get they tend to be trivial pieces of
code but they're valuable log n reflects
logarithmic runtime you can sort of read
the rest of them these are the kinds of
things we're going to deal with we are
going to see examples here here and here
and later on we're come back and see
these which are really nice examples to
have just to remind you why these orders
of growth matter sorry that's just
reminding you what they look like we've
already done that here's the difference
between constant log linear log linear
squared and exponential when n is equal
to ten a hundred a thousand or a million
I know you know this but I want to drive
home the difference something that's
constant is wonderful no matter how big
the problem is takes the same amount of
time
something that law that is log is pretty
nice increases the size of the problem
by ten it increases by a factor of two
from another ten it only increases by a
factor of another fifty percent it only
increases a little bit that's a gorgeous
kind of problem to have linear not so
bad I go from ten to a hundred to a
thousand to a million you can see log
linear is not bad either right a factor
of ten increase here is only a factor of
twenty increase there a factor of ten
increase there is only a factor of
thirty increase there so log linear
doesn't grow that badly but look at the
difference between N squared and two to
the N I actually did think of print
this out by the way Python will compute
this but it was taking pages and pages
and pages I didn't want to do it you get
the point
exponential always much worse always
much worse than then then a quadratic
order or a power expression and you
really see the difference here okay
alright the reason I put this up is as
you design algorithms your goal is to be
as high up in this listing as you can
closer you are to the top of this list
the better off you are if you have a
solution that's down here bring a
sleeping bag and some coffee you're
going to be there for a while right you
really want to try and avoid that if you
can so now what we want to do both for
the rest of today last 15 minutes and
then next week you start identifying
common algorithms and what is their
complexity and as I said to you way back
at the beginning of this lecture which
I'm sure you remember it's not just to
be able to identify the complexity I
want you to see how choices in algorithm
design are going to lead to particular
kinds of consequences in terms of what
this is going to cost you that's your
goal here all right you've already seen
some examples I'm going to do one more
here but simple iterative loop
algorithms are typically linear here's
another version of searching imagine
I'll have an unsorted list arbitrary
order here's another way of doing the
linear search looks a little bit faster
I'm going to set a flag initially
defaults and then I got a loop for i
from 0 up to the length of L I'm going
to use that to index into the list pull
out each element of the list in turn and
check to see is it the thing I'm looking
for as soon as I find it I'm going to
send sorry set the flag to true ok so
that when I return out of the loop I can
just return found and if I found it'll
be true if I'd never found it found will
still be false and I'll return it we
could count the operations here but
you've already seen examples of doing
that this is linear because I'm blooping
n times if n is the length of the list
over there
the number of things I do inside the
loop is constant now you might say wait
a minute this is really brain-damaged or
if you're being more politically correct
computationally challenged okay in the
sense of once I found it why bother
looking at the rest of the list so in
fact I could just return true right here
does that change the order of growth of
this algorithm no changes the average
time I'm going to stop faster but
remember the order of growth captures
what's the worst-case behavior in the
worst case behavior is the elements not
in the list I got to look at everything
so this will be an example of a linear
algorithm and you can see I'm looping
length of L times over the loop inside
of there it's taking the order one to
test it so it's order n and if I were to
actually count it there's the expression
it's one plus four n plus 1 which is 4 n
plus 2 which by my rule says I don't
care about the additive constant I only
care about the dominant term and I don't
care about that multiple multiplicative
constant its order in an example of a
template you're going to see a lot now
okay order n where n is the length of
the list and I need to specify that
that's the thing I'm after if you think
about it I cheated sorry I never cheat
I'm tenured I never cheat I just mislead
you badly not a chance how do I know
that accessing an element of the list
takes constant time I made an assumption
about that and this is a reasonable
thing to ask about both what am i
assuming about the constant operations
and how do I know that's actually true
well it gives me a chance to point out
something that Python does very
effectively not all out languages do but
think about a lift suppose I've got a
list that's all integers I'm going to
need some amount of memory to represent
each integer so if a byte is eight bits
I might reserve four bytes or 32 bits to
cover any reasonable sized integer when
I represent a list I could simply have
each of them in turn so what do I need
to know I'm going to allocate
out on particular length say four bytes
32 bits 32 sequential elements of memory
to represent each integer and then I
just need to know where is the first
part of the list what's the address in
memory of the first part of the list and
to get to the eye element I take that
base plus 4 bytes times I and I can go
straight to this point without having to
walk down the list that's nice
ok it says in fact I can get to any
element of memory I don't try any
element of the list in constant time ok
now what if the things I'm representing
art integers they're arbitrary things
and they take up a big chunk of space
well if the list is heterogeneous we use
a nice technique called indirection
and that simply says we again have a
list we know the address of this point
we know the address therefore the
element of this list but inside of here
we don't store the actual value we store
a pointer to where it is in memory just
what these things are indicating so they
can be arbitrary size but again I can
get to any element in constant time
which is exactly what I want so that's
great
ok now suppose I tell you that the list
is sorted it's an increasing order I can
be more clever about my algorithm
because now as I loop through it I can
say if it's the thing I'm looking for
just return true if the element of the
list is bigger than the thing I'm
looking for I'm done I don't need to
look at the rest of the list because I
know it can't be there because it's
ordered or sorted I can just return
false if I get all the way through the
loop I can return false so I only have
to look until I get to a point where the
thing in the list is bigger than what
I'm looking for
it's the order of growth here gain the
average time behavior will be faster but
the order of growth is I've got to do
order of length of the list to go
through the loop order of 1 to do the
test and in the worst case again I still
have to go through the entire list so
the order of growth here is the same it
is a gain linear in the length of the
list even though the runtime will be
different depending on whether it's
sorted or not
I want you to hold onto that idea
because we're going to come back to the
sorted list next week to see that there
actually are much more efficient ways to
use the fact that a list is sorted to do
the search but both of these versions
same order growth order n okay okay so
lurch it now
lurching through a list right sorry
searching through a list in sequence is
linear because of that loop there are
other things that have a similar flavor
and I'm going to do these quickly to get
to the last example imagine I give you a
string of characters that are all
assumed to be composed of decimal digits
I just want to add them all up this is
also linear because there's the loop I'm
going to loop over the characters in the
string I'm going to cast them into
integers add them in and return the
value this is linear in the length of
the input s notice the pattern that loop
that in iterative loop it's got that
linear behavior because inside of the
loop constant number of things that I'm
executing we already looked at fact ador
same idea there's the loop I'm going to
do that end times inside the loop a
constant amount of things so we're
looping around at is order n there's the
actual expression but again the pattern
I want you to see here is that this is
order n okay last example for today I
know you're all secretly looking at your
watches standard loops typically linear
what about nested loops what about loops
that have loops inside of them how long
do they take and I want to show you a
couple of examples and mostly I want to
show you how to reason about them
suppose I gave you two lists composed of
integers and I want to know is the first
list a subset of the second list codes
in the hand oh by the way if you want to
go run it but basically the simple idea
would be I'm going to loop over every
element in the first list and for each
one of those I want to say is it in the
second list so I'll use the same kind of
trick I'll set up a flag that's
initially false and then I'm going to
loop over everything in the second list
and if that thing is equal to the thing
I'm looking for
we'll set match to true and break out of
the loop the inner loop
if I get all the way through the second
list and I haven't found the thing I'm
looking for when I break out or come out
of this loop matched in that case we'll
still be false and I'll return false
but if up here I found something that
matched match will be true I break out
of it it's not false therefore a return
true I want you to look at the code you
should be able to look at this and
realize what it's doing for each element
in the first list I walk through the
second list to say is that element there
if it is I return true if that's true
for all of the elements in the first
list I return true overall okay order of
growth outer loop this loop I'm going to
execute the length of l1 times all right
I've got to walk down that first list if
I call that end it's going to take that
end times over the over loop outer loop
but what about in here all of the
earlier examples we had a constant
number of operations inside of the loop
here we don't we've got another loop
that's looping over and put it in put in
principle all the elements of the second
list so in each iteration is going to
execute the inner loop up to length of
l2 times we're inside of this inner loop
there is a constant number of operations
ah nice that's the multiplicative law of
orders of growth
it says if this is order length l1 and
we're going to do that then order length
of L 2 times the order growth is a
product in the most common or the worst
case behavior is going to be when the
lists are of the same length and none of
the elements of l1 or in l2 and in that
case we're going to get something that's
order N squared
quadratic where n is the length of the
list in terms of number of operations I
don't really care about subsets I got
one more example we could similarly do
intersection I want to say what is the
intersection of two lists what elements
are in both list one and list two same
basic idea here I've got a pair of
nested loops I'm looping over everything
in l1 for that I'm looping over
everything
in l2 and if they are the same I want to
put that into my temporary variable once
I've done that I need to clean things up
so I'm going to write another loop that
sets up an internal variable and then
runs through everything in the list I
accumulated making sure that it's not
already there and as long as it is and
I'm going to put it into the result and
return it I did it quickly you can look
through it you'll see it does the right
thing what I want you to see is what's
the order of growth I need to look at
this piece then I need to look at that
piece this piece well its order length
l1 to do the or outer loop for each
version of e1 I've got to do order of
length l2 things inside to accumulate
them so that's quadratic what about the
second loop well this one is a little
more subtle
I'm only looping over temp which is at
most going to be length l1 long but I'm
checking to see is that element in a
list and it depends on the
implementation but typically that's
going to take up to the length of the
list to do it I got a look to see is it
there or not and so that inner loop if
we assume the lists are the same size is
also going to take potentially up to
length l1 steps and so this is again
quadratic it's actually two quadratics
one for the first nested loop one for
the second one because there's an
implicit second loop right there but
overall it's quadratic so what you see
in general this is a really dumb way to
compute N squared when you have nested
loops typically it's going to be
quadratic behavior and so what we've
done then is we started to build up
examples now seen simple looping
mechanism simple iterative mechanisms
nested loops they tend to naturally give
rise to linear and quadratic complexity
and next time we're going to start
looking at more interesting classes and
we'll see you next time